te acuerdas de la media aritmética a ver
repasemos la un poquito porque por
alguna extraña razón tiene que ver con
la esperanza entonces vamos a empezar
por allí digamos que tenemos una
población de números 3
4 y 5 y queremos sacar la media
aritmética de esta población de números
entonces lo que hacemos es sumarlos
todos tres más tres más tres más 45 y
dividirlo entre el número de individuos
en la población lo que hay en este caso
es 1 2 3 4 5 tenemos que dividir entre 5
y esto es igual a tres más tres más 3 es
9 más 4 599 es 10 y 8 entre 5 lo cual es
igual a 3.6 y listo
bueno entonces ya recordamos lo que es
la media aritmética ahora lo que vamos a
hacer es modificar un poco la forma en
la que hacemos las cosas para sacar la
media aritmética porque esta nueva forma
de hacer las cosas puede ser más
generalizable
esto de aquí es exactamente igual a
haber tenemos 313 entonces vamos a poner
por aquí tres por tres más tenemos un
solo cuatro entonces vamos a poner uno
por cuatro más un solo cinco un solo
cinco y estamos dividiendo entre cinco a
ver esto también lo podemos volver a
escribir como tres entre cinco por tres
más uno entre cinco un quinto por cuatro
más uno entre cinco por cinco un quinto
por cinco a ver vamos a necesitar más
más espacio entonces tenemos que ser más
ahorrativos por otro lado también
podemos calcular estas fracciones y lo
que nos queda es punto seis por tres
un quinto es punto dos por cuatro más un
quinto es punto dos por cinco y también
podemos usar los porcentajes multiplicar
por punto 6 es como sacar el 60% de tres
más punto 2 es digamos el 20 por ciento
y lo estamos multiplicando por cuatro
entonces estamos sacando el 20% de 41.2
es otra vez el 20 por ciento y
multiplicamos por 5 a ver recapitulando
teníamos una población de números
sacábamos un media aritmética y lo que
hicimos por aquí fue simplemente
reescribir la media aritmética de otra
forma ok esto de aquí también es igual a
3.6 que es la media aritmética de esta
población de números
ahora si nosotros tuviéramos una
variable aleatoria x que lo que hiciera
fuera es [ __ ] alguno de estos cinco
números al azar donde la probabilidad de
escoger a cada uno de ellos sea la misma
para todos entonces resulta que este
número de aquí es la esperanza de x
ahora no siempre podemos encontrar la
media aritmética ok en este caso donde
tenemos únicamente cinco números es muy
fácil y muy directo saber cuántos
elementos hay de cada uno de los números
en cuestión o sea sabemos que hay tres
números tres y sabemos que hay un número
cuatro y un número cinco y entonces
sacamos muy fácilmente la media
aritmética ahora hay variables
aleatorias mucho más complicadas donde
tenemos muchísimos números ok o donde la
probabilidad de escoger a cada número no
es la misma o sea tal vez la
probabilidad de escoger a 5 es mucho más
alta que la probabilidad de escoger a
tres oa cuatro
6 para tener una forma más general de la
media aritmética lo que hacemos es en
lugar de contar cuántos individuos hay
de cada tipo ponemos cuál es la
probabilidad de escoger a cada elemento
que hay hay una probabilidad de un
quinto de escoger al elemento 4 y una
probabilidad de un quinto de escoger al
elemento 5 y una de tres quintos de
escoger al elemento 3 que después vimos
que se simplifica con estos números
y estos números tienen la propiedad de
que ni siquiera sabemos cuántos
elementos hay en la población y bueno
así es como se define la esperanza que
la esperanza de una variable aleatoria
es la probabilidad de que x sea igual en
este caso es 3 por el valor que toma x
esto es 3 más la probabilidad de que x
tome algún otro valor por el valor que
toma de la variable x en este caso más
la probabilidad de que x sea igual a 5
por el valor de 5 y listo así es como se
define la esperanza y para qué sirve la
esperanza pues sirve más o menos para
saber en promedio por dónde va a caer la
variable aleatoria ok no nos dice cuál
es el valor más probable sino que
considera a cada uno de los posibles
valores que puede tomar x y los
considera con un peso que es la
probabilidad de que salga ese valor
verdad es que ahorita no estoy
explicando todas las cosas sutiles de la
esperanza porque sería un trabajo muy
difícil pero bueno es necesario hacer
esta generalización y tomar únicamente
la probabilidad con la que la variable
toma algunos valores porque hay
muchísimas veces en las que no podemos
sacar la media aritmética y bueno de
hecho hay otras veces en las que la
media aritmética tampoco nos sirve para
tener una idea de por dónde está la
variable porque no en todos los casos x
va a tomar estos valores con la misma
probabilidad o sea por ejemplo x podría
tomar el 5 con una probabilidad de un
medio y el 4 con una probabilidad de un
medio y tomar estos números con
probabilidades 0 y entonces la media
aritmética seguiría siendo 3.6 pero la
esperanza sería 4.5 porque el 4 por un
medio más 5 por un medio es igual a 4.5
aunque sería la nueva esperanza de x y
esto nos da una mucho mejor idea de por
dónde va a caer la variable x que 3.6 o
sea porque esto lo que nos dice es que
la mitad de las veces va a caer en el 4
y la mitad de las veces va a caer en el
5 entonces sí nos dicen que esperamos un
valor más o menos de 4.5 tenemos una
mejor idea de qué va a pasar con esta
variable aleatoria no pero bueno más
adelante vamos a ver que esto de la
esperanza es muchísimo más complicado
porque podemos tener cosas tan bizarras
como una variable aleatoria que tome el
valor de 1 con probabilidad
un medio y que toma el valor de un
millón con probabilidad
también un medio y entonces la esperanza
de x es igual a ver la mitad de un
millón es 500.000 y la mitad de 1.5
entonces la esperanza de esta variable
aleatoria es 500000 punto 5 que está
lejísimos del 1 y del un millón no bueno
pero pueden llegar a pasar cosas todavía
más extrañas por ejemplo si ponemos por
aquí que la probabilidad de que x sea
igual a 1 es 9 decimos y que la
probabilidad de que x sea igual a un
millón es un décimo entonces la
esperanza de x resulta ser igual a un
millón entre 10 eso es
mil más uno por nueve décimos es punto
nueve y aquí yo opino que sería muy útil
ver la función de probabilidad de masa
entonces vamos a ponerle por aquí está
el 1 y bueno en realidad el 100.000 está
muy lejos para acá cierto pero vamos a
ponerlo por acá
la probabilidad de que x sea igual a 1
es 9 decimos vamos a ponerlo por aquí y
la probabilidad de que x sea igual a un
millón es un décimo o sea que es más o
menos esto en comparación con esto que
por cierto aquí me equivoqué aquí va un
millón y la esperanza cuando tomamos las
probabilidades naranjas es 100.000 punto
9 que es más o menos un décimo de la
distancia entre estos dos puntos
entonces está como por aquí la esperanza
de x de hecho creo que debía haber
dibujado estas probabilidades en naranja
y la esperanza cuando tomamos las
probabilidades verdes está justo a la
mitad que la esperanza de la x verde y
rápidamente graphic hemos las
probabilidades son exactamente iguales
entonces son más o menos
así entonces la esperanza no es
precisamente el promedio de los dos
números como podemos ver en la esperanza
naranja sino que es una especie de media
aritmética donde estamos ponderando el
peso de cada uno de los posibles valores
de la variable x con la probabilidad de
que tomen ese valor bueno algo que
también está muy interesante aquí es que
por la forma en la que escogimos las
probabilidades podemos interpretar a
esta esperanza como la media aritmética
de una población o sea cuando tenemos
aquí un medio y un medio podemos pensar
que tenemos una población de números
donde solo hay un 1 y donde sólo hay 1
un millón ok si sacamos la media
aritmética de esta población de números
lo que vamos a obtener es justamente
esto de aquí porque vamos a obtener uno
por un medio más un millón por un medio
y podemos hacer exactamente lo mismo
para estas probabilidades naranjas nada
más que ahí nos tenemos que ver un
poquito más buzos porque tenemos aquí
que el 1 tiene una probabilidad de 9
décimos de aparecer y un millón tiene
una probabilidad de un décimo de
aparecer entonces lo que vamos a hacer
es poner 9 1 2 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 y poner
uno solo de estos ponemos por aquí
un millón entonces esta es nuestra
población y ahora sí si sacamos la media
aritmética lo que tenemos es uno más uno
más uno más uno más uno más uno más uno
123456789 más un millón
y todo esto entre tenemos 10 números en
total no entonces tenemos que dividir
entre 10 si hacemos las cuentas esta
parte de aquí es punto 9 y esta otra
parte de aquí es 100.000 entonces nos
queda tal cual 100.000 más punto 9 o sea
esta esperanza de aquí entonces en este
ejemplo de esta variable si pudimos
escribir a estas esperanzas como la
media aritmética de una población de
números entonces tenemos unas
representaciones muy bonitas muy
intuitivas de lo que es la esperanza
para esta variable con estas
probabilidades no o sea aquí tenemos la
población y aquí tenemos una
representación muy bonita de lo que
significa que una variable tome cierto
valor con una probabilidad del 9 decimos
sin embargo no todos los experimentos no
todas las variables aleatorias tienen la
misma suerte hay unas que son muchísimo
más abstractas
a ver vamos a ver otro ejemplo aunque y
vamos a poner que x es igual al número
de caras en 6 volados justos
aunque ahí tomamos una moneda la
lanzamos seis veces y nos fijamos en el
número de caras y además estamos
diciendo que la probabilidad de que en
esa moneda salga una cara es exactamente
igual a la probabilidad de que nos salga
una cruz eso lo estamos diciendo al
decir que son volados justos pero bueno
más adelante vamos a ver que este tipo
de variables se llama una variable vino
miel vino miel de parámetros 6.5 ok 6 de
que estamos lanzando 6 volados y punto 5
porque la probabilidad de que salga cara
en cada uno de los volados es igual a
punto 5 pero bueno todo esto de los
parámetros y las probabilidades y todo
eso lo vamos a ver con mucho detalle en
los vídeos de distribución binomial que
si no me equivoco no los hemos cambiado
de lugar están más adelante en esta
lista pero bueno en estos vídeos
calculamos la probabilidad de que
x sea igual a cualquier número entero
entre el 0 y el 6 que son todos los
valores que puede tomar la variable x
náusea o pueden salir 0 caras o puede
salir una cara no pueden salir hasta 6
caras pero bueno para calcular
exactamente estas probabilidades lo que
hicimos fue usar excel aquí tenemos los
valores que puede tomar la variable aquí
en realidad no queremos la probabilidad
de anotar sino la probabilidad de sacar
una cara y aquí la de sacar una cruz y
bueno estas dos columnas las puedes
ignorar por el momento en ese vídeo vas
a tener que ponerle mucha atención pero
por el momento me vas a tener que creer
que hicimos bien todas estas cuentas y
que la probabilidad de sacar cero caras
es punto cero unos 562 y la probabilidad
de sacar seis caras es punto 0 15 6 25
que es igual a la probabilidad de sacar
0 porque tenemos una moneda de justa y
la probabilidad de sacar tres caras es
punto 3 125
entonces para sacar la esperanza de x lo
que tengo que hacer es irme a excel
buscar la probabilidad de sacar 0 que es
este punto 0 15 6 25
y multiplicar esta probabilidad por el
valor que va a tomar la variable x en
ese momento que es 0 más la probabilidad
de que x sea igual a 1 que es 0.09 375
por el valor que va a tomar x en ese
momento que es un 1 más la probabilidad
de que la variable x tome el valor de 2
que es punto 23 4375 punto 23 43 75 por
el valor que toma la variable x que es 2
más y se pueden imaginar no o sea tengo
que escribir todas estas celdas que son
las probabilidades con las que la
variable x toma cada uno de estos
valores y sumarlos todos pero bueno
mejor en lugar de hacer eso vamos a
hacer que excel lo haga entonces aquí
queremos poner vamos a hacer una función
que lo que haga sea multiplicar el valor
que va a tomar la variable x por la
probabilidad con la que toma ese valor
que hay aquí nos sale un cero porque x
toma un valor de 0 y 0 por cualquier
probabilidad de 0 entonces vamos a hacer
que haga lo mismo en todas estas celdas
y aquí vamos a hacer que sume todos
estos valores entonces aquí como podemos
ver en la fórmula de acá lo que está
haciendo es sumando cada una de estas
entradas y eso nos da un valor de 3 en
esta gráfica aquí tenemos cero 1 2 3
así es que la esperanza está justo por
acá lo cual tiene un poco de sentido no
o sea porque las probabilidades son
simétricas entonces lo que aporta la
posibilidad de que x sea igual a 0 es
igual a lo que aporta la posibilidad de
que x sea igual a 6 y el punto medio
entre 6 y 0 es justo el 3 y lo mismo
pasa para estas otras 4 columnas
entonces tiene todo el sentido del mundo
que la esperanza quede justo a la mitad
y bueno coincidió con que cayó en el
valor más probable pero eso no siempre
es el caso como ya vimos en el otro
ejemplo en fin el chiste es que aquí las
probabilidades son tan complejas que no
se pueden o no son fáciles de escribir
como una media aritmética
de una población de números sin embargo
si tenemos la frecuencia con la que esos
números suceden entonces podemos sacar
la media aritmética sin tener que saber
exactamente cuántos individuos hay en la
población de números que está detrás de
esta variable aleatoria ok si
quisiéramos dibujar la población de
números detrás de esta variable estaría
en chino porque en realidad es una
población infinita a ver vamos a
dibujarla por acá nada más que tenemos
que poner flechas hacia todos lados
porque te digo que es una población
infinita aquí porque cada realización de
este experimento que en general las
denotamos con letras chiquitas por
ejemplo x 1 x 2 x 3 bla bla cada uno de
estos para empezar es digamos un vector
con seis entradas aunque hay por ejemplo
k'ara k'ara k'ara cruz cruz cara
cara cruz cruz cara cruz cara y lo que
hay dentro de esta población son todos
los conjuntos de seis volados que se han
hecho en la vida
ok hay millones de puntitos por aquí y
además deberíamos en realidad agregar
todos los conjuntos de seis volados que
se van a tirar en algún momento del
universo ok en realidad si hay una
infinidad de puntitos por aquí y si
sacamos alguno de esos puntitos al azar
que para hacer eso lo único que tenemos
que hacer es tirar una moneda seis veces
entonces la probabilidad de que en ese
puntito x valga tanto es igual a la
proporción de puntos en esta población
infinita en los que x vale justo esa
cantidad por la que nos estamos
preguntando cuál es la probabilidad ok
si nos preguntamos cuál es la
probabilidad de que x sea igual a 3
entonces tenemos que ver de toda esta
población
qué proporción de puntos es en la que x
vale 3 y esa proporción es justo esta
probabilidad y entonces la esperanza de
x xi es la media aritmética de esta
población de puntitos sin embargo como
tenemos una infinidad de puntitos
entonces en realidad no podemos hacer
las cuentas de la media aritmética y a
lo único a lo que podemos recurrir es a
las frecuencias con las que salen los
puntitos en los que x vale tanto o equis
vale 10 o equis vale 2
pero bueno sintetizando lo todo la
esperanza de una variable aleatoria x es
igual a la suma sobre todos los valores
que toma x y corre sobre todos los
valores de x
valores que puede tomar x qué
puede
x y lo que estamos sumando es la
probabilidad de que x sea igual a alguno
de los valores que puede tomar por el
valor que está tomando x en cada uno de
estos puntitos aunque esta es la forma
formal de escribir lo que significa la
esperanza de x
así es que recuerda la muy bien